the song is called dilemma this is about
addiction yeah some of the lyrics in
here I was sober now I'm drunk again I'm
in trouble and in love again I don't
want to be a dead man walking Welcome To
My Nightmare where dreams go to
disappear sit around in rehab feeling
like a lab rat strange days are here
again and it's getting weirder here's to
all my problems I just want to drink the
poison I don't want to be a dead man
walking yeah and I think maybe what
you're saying in the song again this is
me putting my into you like when
you fall off the wagon it's like how
come I can't control this how come I
can't defeat it you know I was sober for
5 years and then I thought that I could
kind of go back and be like a you know
just a normal Drinker again or some like
and I think I was for a little bit and
then it just escalated and it just got
to a point where I was you know
physically and mentally just drained and
um I just felt terrible I got tired of I
got tired of feeling tired as they say
you know this song was written while I I
was drinking you know and it was uh it's
a strange feeling it's like one of the
most honest songs I've ever written
there's nothing about it that is like a
um there's no like metaphor or anything
like that it's just like one of the most
honest songs I've ever written it's one
of my favorites on the new album I
responded to it right away because of
its honesty and also it's a damn catchy
song but yeah I I really felt your pain
but I've got a great group of friends
that I go out with and we go see shows
and um we're still able to have a a good
sexy night life you know so it's a good
you know night out but we just do it
without drinking you know so um you know
the fact that I got up and was able to
do this so early in the morning to come
to your show is like and feel good right
now um you that's an accomplishment for
me believe me we've definitely come in
in your show definitely hung over
yes